[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
fresh off the heels of a federal
conviction in the death of george floyd
three ex-minnesota officers motioned for
a mistrial plus january 6 arrests and
convictions the latest developments out
of washington d.c and nearly 20 years
after georgia beauty queen tara
grinstead went missing both her accused
killers appear in the same courtroom mr
dukes did agent shout out interview you
first on june 16
2016. under the advice of council i'm
invoking my fifth member right not to
testify
but first federal jury selection begins
in the trial of ramich sunny bawwani a
one-time theranos ceo and ex-lover of
elizabeth holmes von crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin jury selection is underway in two
high-profile federal cases on both sides
of the country in new york federal
attorneys work to seat a jury in the
case of accused sarah lawrence college
cult leader lawrence ray and in
california jury selection begins for a
one-time theranos ceo
ramesh sunny bowani bowani faces 12
federal fraud charges in relation to his
time with the now defunct company
theranos founded by now convicted
froster elizabeth holmes theranos was
touted as a company that would
revolutionize blood testing with its
state-of-the-art edison device later
tests found many problems with the
device in a federal trial spanning
months holmes pointed the finger at
belwani her former boyfriend and their
nose business partner holmes testified
that bowani emotionally and physically
abused her and even forced her to have
sex with him against her will
prosecutors countered saying holmes knew
about the company's issues and lied her
way into millions of dollars in january
a federal jury found holmes guilty on
multiple accounts
the same federal judge who presided over
holmes case will take on pawani's trial
he has pled not guilty to all charges
his trial is expected to last for months
joining us today is civil rights
attorney philip hamilton and terry
austin to break down the second theranos
trial philip does the fact that
elizabeth holmes is already convicted of
similar charges help or hurt balwani
it hurts bon wani because essentially at
this point the government has had an
entire rundown of how to effectively
prosecute a case essentially on the same
fact and with respect to the narrative
brian in many respects this case is the
public's fear of missing out combined
with the companies faking it until
you're making it and to the extent that
those two concepts had a baby it's this
case and the public is not happy about
it i think in many respects that's why
we saw the conviction in the first trial
and it really sets up the government to
prosecute well i believe in this so i
think it hurts which is interesting
because your answer kind of sets up my
question to terry do you anticipate the
prosecution using the holmes playbook to
convict bowani or is this going to be a
whole new type of prosecution
i think it's going to be similar i don't
think it's going to be a whole new type
of prosecution but it is a little bit
different because he was not the
ultimate decision maker he was the ceo
remember he oversaw the lab and he in
fact did make some decisions and i think
the prosecution is going to focus on
that but there's a difference here he
didn't have the last word you remember
in the trial involving holmes we heard
erica chung who was a former lab worker
she said that balwani actually rebuffed
some of her concerns about the
technology i think that type of evidence
is something the prosecution is going to
want to show here that he knew about the
problems with theranos and he did
nothing to make a difference as far as
that's concerned so i think it's going
to be a similar playbook but it won't be
exactly the same the question is will
they bring up the issues as far as the
relationship was concerned yeah and i'm
and i'm curious as to whether or not
bolwani takes the stand and testifies i
think he has a good argument saying hey
i don't know the science i'm just a
businessman trying to make money it's
gonna be interesting to see how the
prosecution maybe changes up this uh
this case a little to try to get that
conviction well moving on to the east
coast where a lengthy jury selection
process is expected in the trial of
accused sarah lawrence college cult
leader lawrence ray for about 10 years
ray allegedly abused and extorted
several of his daughter's classmates who
were students at sarah lawrence college
it all started when the 62-year-old
former wall street trader moved into his
daughter's on-campus housing in 2010
just days after being released from
prison officials say he soon gained
control over his daughter's friends
presenting himself as a father figure
and holding group therapy sessions over
the next 10 years he allegedly extorted
money from the students and isolated
them from their families even moving
them into apartments in new york city
then eventually to north carolina his
alleged crimes were investigated after
authorities caught wind of a 2019 new
york magazine article revealing the
abuse and manipulation one of the
students was indicted for her role in
the scheme she will face a separate
trial set for this summer rey faces a 17
count indictment including charges of
racketeering sex trafficking forced
labor money laundering and tax evasion
he faces life in prison if convicted
long crime network's adam klasfeldt is
covering the trial extensively he will
bring us the latest news as the story
develops
and the sex abuse lawsuit involving
prince andrew was formally dismissed by
a judge this comes just three weeks
after accuser virginia dufrey and the
duke of york reached an out-of-court
settlement a judge signed off on the
dismissal tuesday after request from
lawyers on both sides of the deal drew
frey alleged disgraced businessman
jeffrey epstein had trafficked her to
prince andrew saying he took advantage
of her and sexually abused her when she
was under 18. joffrey previously settled
with epstein in 2009 over trafficking
allegations before epstein was found
dead in his jail cell ahead of a federal
trial for allegedly sexually abusing
young girls andrews settled would you
frey after a judge rejected his request
to dismiss the case no details were
released on the sum of the settlements
the lawsuit was dismissed with prejudice
which means it cannot be refiled
and in california a woman accused of
lying to the fbi and faking her own
abduction is free on bail a federal
judge set papini's bail at 120 thousand
dollars and she posted it federal
prosecutors had asked that papini be
kept in jail when papini went missing in
november 2016.
law enforcement launched a massive
search for the wife and mother of two
she appeared 22 days later on an
interstate claiming two hispanic women
kidnapped and tortured her but
prosecutors say it was all a lie and
that papini was with her ex-boyfriend
she's also accused of defrauding the
california victims compensation board of
thirty thousand dollars
still ahead on law and crime daily
albert is handed down for the first
defendant tried in connection to the
january 6 capital attack but first the
murder of tara grinstead an accused
murderer will soon stand trial the
latest developments in the case of ryan
duke
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
youtubetv today and then locate law and
crime in the channel guide and for only
1.99 a month you can add the network to
your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
head to georgia as testimony in a
pre-trial hearing ends with a
co-defendant pleading the fifth in the
case of missing teacher and former
beauty queen tara grinstead grinstead
went missing in 2005 in the small town
of osilla georgia and was declared dead
five years later after the search went
cold years later a tip led the to the
arrest of ryan duke and beau dukes two
21 year olds who had previously attended
the school where grinstead worked duke
is charged with malice murder felony
murder and assault among other charges
his case heads to trial in may dukes's
case has already gone to trial he was
found guilty of making false statements
and concealing the death of a person
dukes was set to testify at this week's
pre-trial hearing on tuesday he took the
stand and it was agreed that he would
come back wednesday so he could have a
lawyer present there's been some debate
over dukes being offered a deal for his
cooperation one question on wednesday
about meetings he had with law
enforcement in 2017 he plead the fifth
but the judge did require dukes to
answer one question
was it during that meeting that mr
bowden told you that if you cooperated
and you were not involved in the
homicide but you were only involved in
the cover-up that they would be in a
position to help you under the advice of
council i'm invoking my fifth amendment
right not to self-incriminate and it was
shortly after mr bowden made this
statement to you that you made a
statement that implicated ryan duke
under the advice of council on invoking
my fifth amendment right not to
self-recriminate did you know paul
bowden prior to this meeting under the
advice of council i'm invoking my fifth
member right now to testify and judge
that one i would argue does not have any
um incriminating statements i'm going to
require the witness to answer that
question
personally i did not know mr bowden have
you ever met him that day
not that i recall it's possible though
were you friends with his son josh yes
had you ever been to the boundless home
i can't recall a time where i ever was
the pre-trial hearing continues into his
third day on thursday let's bring back
civil rights attorney philip hamilton
and terry austin to discuss this
pre-trial hearing for the death of tara
grinston terry beau dukes has already
been convicted in connection with
grinstead's death so
why do you think he decided to plead the
fifth
well you know there's only one reason
why he's not talking and that's because
he doesn't want to be further implicated
in grinstead's death the fact is he was
convicted as you mentioned in march of
2019 it was a four-day trial it took the
jury less than an hour to come to that
conviction and the counts were making
false statements hindering apprehension
of a criminal concealing the death but
he wasn't convicted of the murder of
grinstead and he's afraid if he gets up
on that stand he doesn't have immunity
he's afraid he's going to implicate
himself so that is the sole reason he
took the fifth we're not going to hear
any further well philip
why should we watching these pre-trial
hearings how do they affect the actual
trial and were there any major arguments
that you think could affect ryan duke's
case going forward
ryan pre-trial hearings always set the
stage in the framework for what the
trial is going to look like whether
you're the prosecution or you're the
defense you typically prepare your case
in any given amount of three to four to
seven ways depending upon how the judge
is going to decide evidentiarily what's
coming in and what's not so to the
extent that both sides are able to
figure out what ultimately is going to
be presented and what's not it sets
their strategy for approaching the case
you know in regards to the arguments
that will be helpful i think in many
respects it's going to depend upon
what's allowed in from a statement
perspective what's allowed in from a
physical evidence perspective and what's
not so ultimately once that decision is
made we'll see yeah and of course now we
know that if the co-defendant does take
the stand he's gonna plead the fifth so
that's gonna be a big thing for both
sides as they continue
switching now to ohio as the murder
trial for former dr william hussell
moves into another day of testimony on
wednesday jurors heard from several
former nurses who worked alongside
whosoe at mount carmel hospital in
columbus husell is accused of ordering
excessive amounts of fentanyl to be
administered to over a dozen patients he
was treating in the icu from 2015
through 2018. his defense team argues he
was giving end-of-life comfort care and
not attempting to shorten the lives of
his patients originally the former
doctor was charged in the deaths of 25
patients 11 of the charges were dropped
earlier this year 25 mount caramel
nurses were issue notices by the ohio
board of nursing one nurse was maria
bard who sells wife they were part of
the nearly 50 health care professionals
who were put under review during the
investigation wednesday morning former
nurses testified about being ordered to
administer fentanyl to patients
what happened when you got up there as
rapid response nurse i met dr hussell
and tyler springer at the pixas where i
received a brief report
about the patient and the orders given
for the palliative withdrawal and what
were the orders you were given for the
palliative withdrawal medication
thousand of fentanyl okay ten a versa
and ten of dilaudid okay and did you
withdraw those from the pixas machine
sir
i withdrew part of the order okay tyler
springer had initially began withdrawing
when i took over mr redmond you withdrew
these upon the order of dr hussell
correct so i
believe it was somewhere in the
ten o'clock hour didn't seem like the
pain medicine was kind of helping her
she was
a lot more like rigid tense
more labored breathing
grimacing she had a tear running down
her
her face
and
after like talking with the
the son and the granddaughter who also
agreed that they thought that she was
um
in more pain and wanted more pain
medicine i called dr fusel dr husel
comes to the bedside kind of assesses
the patient talks to the family about
about
giving her more medication if they want
it and they agreed okay
so what happens next um so then dr we
step out he had he ordered he verbally
told me the order of the thousand
micrograms of fentanyl and the ten of
person
coming up on law and crime daily a
surprising motion made just weeks after
three ex-minnesota police officers were
convicted in the death of george floyd
plus a conviction and arrest in
connection to the january 6 insurrection
at the united states capitol the latest
developments in both cases still ahead
on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back the first january 6 rider
to go to trial is found guilty on all
counts on tuesday a jury found 49 year
old guy refered guilty of five counts
including transporting a firearm in
support of civil disorder and
obstruction of an official proceeding
the federal jury deliberated for less
than four hours this verdict comes after
a week-long trial featuring testimony
from reference teenage son jackson who
tipped off the fbi before the january 6
attacks jackson recorded audio of family
fights and forwarded incriminating text
messages to investigators calling his
father a far-right extremist refit was
one of more than 500 people who could
face charges for their involvement with
the so-called three percenters who
rioted at the u.s capitol on january 6
2021. refin now faces a maximum of 20
years in prison sentencing is set for
june 8.
also on tuesday proud boys leader henry
enrique tario is arrested and charged
with conspiracy in the january 6 capital
insurrection while tario was not in
washington d.c at the time of the riots
court documents show he did meet up with
oathkeeper leader stuart rhodes leading
up to the attack the department of
justice says tario and co-defendants
quote conspire to corruptly obstruct
influence and impede an official
proceeding though tario was not accused
of physically breaching the capital the
doj indictment alleges he helped plan
the attack and stayed in close contact
with other proud boy members during the
capital breach tara was arrested from
his florida home on tuesday and is being
held until a detent until a detention
hearing set for friday the doj has asked
that target remain in custody until
trial saying he's a threat to the public
and a flight risk
civil rights attorney philip hamilton
and co-host terry austin are back as we
discuss these two january 6 cases terry
refit is the first to be found guilty
and only as i said just after four hours
and faces 20 years in jail do you think
this will push more defendants to take
please
i definitely think we're going to see
more pleas in this case you know right
now there have actually been
786 people who've been arrested and
charged with crimes and the fbi is still
looking to find additional people they
asked the public for help
we know that there was not a bipartisan
commission in the senate that was
established the house is continuing to
investigate this matter but the doj no
matter what the house does no matter
what the senate does the doj said they
are going to pursue these and we know
that oath keepers has already been
pursued they've been charged with you
know seditious conspiracy that's a very
serious crime so i definitely think
we're going to see people who want to
take pleas in this case yeah i mean
philip
let's focus now ontario's case a 30-page
indictment says taro's emails and social
media connected him to this january 6
riot so
what's his defense if he's not pleading
guilty
i mean his weakest defense would be to
say that hey i wasn't there because at
the end of the day based upon the
indictment the emails there's enough of
acts there to put him in the conspiracy
that ultimately led to what happened on
january 6. his best defense at this
point probably just arose yesterday with
a decision from district judge in dc
carl nichols who noted that a person
cannot actually be charged with
obstruction where their acts did not
affect a document record or other object
right so the extent to the extent that
people stormed the capital and congress
ultimately ended up running out does
that necessarily actually affect the
federal obstruction law we now have a
federal judge saying no so that may
actually help tario in terms of at least
coming with the defense until some
higher courts rule on that particular
decision all right we'll see how these
courts decide this case as it continues
we'll make sure to give you updates when
we come back new developments in the
federal case of ex-officers to tao
thomas lane and jay alexander king hear
why the newly convicted defendants say
they deserve a mistrial that's still
ahead on law and crime daily
welcome back to law and crime daily just
weeks after all three ex-officers are
found guilty in the death of george
floyd court documents are filed
requesting a mistrial as long crime
daily reported ex-officers two tao
thomas lane and jay alexander king were
convicted by a federal jury out of
minnesota all three were charged in
connection to the death of george floyd
prosecutors say they deprived floyd of
his rights in may 2020 when they fail to
step in as convicted ex-officer derek
chauvin knelt on floyd's neck the
defendants could face a wide range of
sentences for the crime guidelines
recommend a sentence of up to 30 years
but a judge could use his discretion and
send to the defendants to months or no
time at all before a sentencing hearing
was even set all three defendants filed
a motion for mistrial citing
prosecutorial misconduct saying their
rights to a fair trial and impartial
trial were breached by trial orders and
arguments that violated the rules of
criminal procedure and unprofessionalism
in front of the jury the motions for a
mistrial were filed on monday and
tuesday of this week
philip miss trial for prosecutory
misconduct what's that mean and what do
the defendants have to prove in order to
get a new trial
and i'll start with the latter brian
typically what has to be proven is that
the prosecution acted in a way or failed
to act in a way that improperly swayed
the jury into wrongly convicting the
defendant or defendant in this matter
that sometimes can mean whether they
improperly introduce evidence whether
they fail to disclose exculpatory
evidence use improper evidence or in
some other way acted improper throughout
the course of the proceeding it is a
very high burden to prove and even to
the extent that it is successfully
proved it's even harder to then turn
that successful proving of a
prosecutorial misconduct into the remedy
that most likely they would be looking
for which would either be the reversal
of the conviction and or a new trial all
right so it's hard to do but tara let's
give us some more specific facts here
does the defense have a strong argument
here or is this just a motion to be
filed
i think it was a hail mary motion to be
filed i think philip is absolutely
correct they do not have a case here
they filed the motion originally it was
king's attorney who filed and then the
others joined you have to show that it
was willful engagement and misconduct
and that it absolutely prejudiced the
defendant they can't show that here what
their main argument is during the
opening statements they're trying to say
that truffle who was the prosecuting
attorney here during the opening she did
more than just make a statement she
argued and she gave more than a preview
not good enough yeah well we'll see how
it plays out and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you